i'm so nervous i've never done this
at home without the supervision of a
television show
[Music]
hello i'm hannah hart and welcome to
edible history the show that helps you
time travel with your taste buds
growing up i saw cheesecake as maybe the
fanciest of desserts new york cheesecake
you're telling me they fly this stuff
around the world all from new york
of course now i know that not all
cheesecake comes from new york but it
has me wondering where did it come from
to find out i'm chatting with kathy
kaufman the president of the culinary
historians of new york where would you
say that what we consider the cheesecake
started from it is very much a
mediterranean european sort of dish
because most other cultures didn't
depend on dairy that much what inspired
the recipes that later became cheesecake
it's the original cheesecake recipes
that were written by kate of the elder
in the mid 2nd century bce cato was a
roman senator his famous line at every
senate meeting was carthage must be
destroyed because he was a real hawk but
anyway he wrote this book called on
farming there's some fabulous recipes
and a lot of what those recipes involve
are ways of using fresh cheese did it
ever have any roots in nobility or being
fancy the cheesecake from what we can
tell
was a dessert that was going to appeal
to the well-to-do folks so i'm going to
be trying to make one of kato's recipes
but i can't
pronounce it it's salamana uh so willa
so willam it is very much
like what we think of as a modern
cheesecake maybe this will make me fall
back in love with cheesecake i mean
we'll see the first thing a cheesecake
needs is cheese making cheese is
incredibly simple basically you need two
ingredients milk and acid which in this
case is lemon juice and a heat source
we simmer the milk
we add an acid and that's it you know it
really fascinates me that someone way
back in the day thought i'm gonna take a
lemon and add it to milk who would want
that all right how's this doing oh yep
that's curdled milk so the way we turn
curdled milk into cheese is actually
pretty easy
wow so we've got our curds and whey all
mixed together but when we use our
cheesecloth and give it a little squeeze
we end up with some cheese and now it's
time to move on to the rest of the
cheesecake our next step is to flavor
our ricotta with honey but not just any
honey we actually were able to get honey
from attica
delicious
now it's time to see how this cheese
turned out
oh
very cool
very very cool
this looks fantastic okay so we're gonna
put it in our big bowl
and now we're gonna blend it with about
a half a pound of flour
[Music]
one egg
hard egg
[Music]
sounds good
and last but not least our beautiful
beautiful honey i mean who wouldn't want
to just stick this in their mouth
just a couple hearty swizzles whoa
i feel like winnie the pooh
and guess what that's the last of our
ingredients this is the soyum
all right now we need to prepare
[Applause]
our dish for baking so we're going to
take a little beautiful olive oil and
grease this puppy up
hmm
think about your farm your future farm
your gentleman's farm
the farm you have when the life of
entertainment is over
it's time to just retire
maybe take up woodworking
maybe raise some chic
you could probably knit
that'll be great
[Music]
so many cats let's add a couple
spoonfuls
evenly distribute your batter
it's kind of like having a zen garden
you know where you just move the sand
around
it's very relaxing
i'm gonna make soil all the time
okay now it's time to bake this thing is
pretty dense so you want to make sure
that the center is cooked thoroughly as
kato says for it is deepest there so
cover it with the lid
check on it when it's about 90
and that's it
did somebody say sir willem
here it is
oh
yeah
i am for one very excited so you can see
that the edge has a nice dark ring so we
know for sure it's cooked all the way
there let's see if it jiggles at all
oh no
oh that's cooked that's cooked all the
way through
perfect
kato can see me now
next we're gonna do a layer of honey on
top
ah let's get a little more oh
gorgeous
you want to make sure your honey
distributes as evenly as possible and
this stuff is so thick and so viscous
it's not really going to spread so you
got to kind of just encourage it
now that your honey is pretty evenly
dispersed we're gonna give it a hearty
sprinkle of poppy seeds and then we just
cover it up
and stick it back in the oven
[Music]
here we go
i gotta say this thing
it smells delicious
oh wow
i'm feeling super proud this looks great
i can't wait to eat it in a couple hours
because it's kind of cool
and that's pretty much all i can wait
and kato even went so far as to say
serve in the dish and eat it with a
spoon here we go
okay
well it smells great
mmm
if bread pudding and cheesecake had a
delicious baby it would be so willem i'm
still on the fence about cheesecake but
i can say that i do in fact like its
ancestor so willem and it might make a
great party dish you know pour it into a
bunch of little ramekins hand it to
people say oh this is from ancient rome
what who me how did i know that i don't
know i watched a new amazing show called
edible history you're welcome
you